my name is Matt Welch I'm the
editor-in-chief of Reason magazine
Nicholas bees the editor of recent
online and TV he's somewhere here say
hello that's him there and I wanted to
thank you we're just going to talk for
about a half an hour here lightning
round from the beginning of questions
and Dave Weigel is going to set the
table for us a little bit let's leave it
over to our great political reporter
Dave White i will briefly introduce
everyone and then we'll start asking
questions Wayne Allyn root is a sports
celebrity a self-made self-made
businessman millionaire by the age of 30
our next panelist is Mike Ravel a
microphone was a senator from alaska
from nineteen sixty nine to nineteen
eighty-one bob barr he was a congressman
from georgia from 1995 to 2003 he joined
the libertarian National Committee in
2006 and our final panelist is burned
McKinley he is a consultant businessman
a former researcher for several
libertarian think tanks and he's running
for Congress as a Republican in Virginia
against an incumbent Republican who's
basically pretty awful big government
Republican tell everyone well why you're
running why this is your year I think I
can get people excited with the dynamic
youthful enthusiastic speaking style and
message that really will catch the
attention of all the young people are
followed rockwall we all know that money
in politics is what corrupts politics
and we've seen this year more corruption
than ever taken place in our history you
think you're going to see a change next
year for what we have it'll be more of
the same inside the heart of every
American beats the heart of a
libertarian and what we need to do is
show the American People that that is
mainstream for too long libertarians
have been silent there's a lot of
turmoil in the Republican Party right
now I
last week you saw these discussions
about chaos in the party a lot of the
the moderate big government types are
getting pushed out of the party and it's
a great opportunity with dr. Paul's lead
and others to take back the party like
was done in the in the early 80s and mid
90s do we have an immigration problem
first question I love immigrants if
immigrants came here without expecting
welfare aid to dependent families child
support housing free of housing
assistance free public schools free
medical social security if you could net
wave a magic wand and tomorrow I would
say open borders would be great let
everyone in I love immigrants but you
can't it's unrealistic so we have to
seal the border to stop the problem and
then figure out what to do with the
people that are already here the people
that I've met immigrants they don't come
here for welfare they come here to work
they come here to work and they'd love
to send their money home to their
families where the money goes a lot
further than it goes here no we've had a
stupid policy in this country I'm a
shame that we're building a fence in our
southern border what we really need to
do is recognize it even as libertarians
the one fundamental function of
government and if there is one
responsibility the government has is to
protect the nation to protect the
sovereignty of the nation and you do
that by assuring yourself that those
people have one of them into America
submit themselves to a basic background
check present verifiable current
identification at a proper border
checkpoint and that you make sure they
don't have a communicable disease but
what we don't want to do is to have any
kind of real ID type of employer
verification program that tracks all the
employees in the country we don't want
to be spending billions when we don't
really have a plan to straighten out the
border situation that's what we've been
doing since 2001 okay next next question
has any foreign intervention by the
United States since the Gulf War been
worth it I just you put me on the spot
as to which one's worth it since 91 I
guess the festival or because there
there wasn't attacks the first Gulf War
I guess you might say was it was one of
those examples where we had to go in and
protect weight and the oil supply but
having said that I certainly don't think
this Iraq war made any sense at all i
think it's a disaster i think we got to
get out as fast as we can war baguettes
war and it started with the first world
war a democrat took us into war we
should have let the Europeans settle
their differences and you not set it up
for the Second World War and then
forward there's no time in history where
you can look at a war and not realize
that did not be get another war we need
to we need to recognize that America
does not serve either itself or the rest
of the world well by intervening
nation-building and occupying for lamps
to clarify none of the intervention
since the Gulf War then keeping in mind
that most were under Bill Clinton no I
think Afghanistan I would have probably
voted for a very targeted intervention
there to take care of al Qaeda because
using Ronald Reagan's national interest
benchmark I think that was something
that was in our national interest but I
wouldn't have stayed there for nation
building like we've done and the Iraq
war i would not have gone in there okay
next question what is the first federal
agency that you would get rid of once
you get behind the desk the Oval Office
that's an easy question for me it's the
Department of Education I think it's a
symbol of everything wrong with our
government today I think it's the great
issue of our time it is the civil rights
issue of our time there are children and
get a gun as hell to our head I think
back to the Boston Tea Party its
taxation without representation when you
force me to beg property taxes to send
my children to public schools and public
schools are failing and I should have a
voucher that allows me to take that
money and choose something else and
unfortunately public school teachers you
do not want our children succeed all
they care about is their own salaries
and it's a sin and it's a disgrace
Department of Education God obviously
the IRS
and our system of revenue has to change
it just give me let me give you the
overarching aspect of it in 24 seconds
24-second aggressive are we tax
individuals we taxed a productive part
of enterprise in corporations we tax our
savings but we don't tax wealth does
that not give a message to the American
people that we got things cattywampus
okay yeah I just live the word
cattywampus I don't think I i was
thinking of another word but i don't
think you want me to say it not same
question first agency you want to get
rid of there is absolutely no reason no
constitutional basis no legitimate basis
for the Federal Department of Education
all they do is spend money and interfere
that would certainly have to be either
at or very near the top of my list for
agencies departments and offices and the
government to get rid of education
obviously energy commerce commerce is
just a broom closet a bunch of functions
that shouldn't be around I mean these
are all planks during the Reagan years
during the the mid-90s Republican
revolution and then this time around we
need to really be serious and get rid of
them all are you willing to legalize the
sale and possession of all narcotics the
war on drugs is the stupidest thing this
country has ever undertaken we know the
failure of prohibition in the 20 and now
there's nothing stopping us and here I
was there Richard Nixon commissioned a
study with the Pennsylvania Governor
Shaffer and the study was to find out
what the story was with respect to drugs
well they came back with a study that
said that marijuana was not addictive
with not a gateway drug and that we
should deregulate the hard drugs and if
you want a hard drug go to a doctor get
a prescription that's what the rest of
us do with drugs right now
what are you talking about speak for
yourself son why not we're swimming
where's what but wait you get older
you'll need some i believe the war on
drugs is a disaster but having said that
the way he elected is to go after issue
the American public and get their hands
around and I think it's always about
medical marijuana if you had an uncle of
you and a father yet someone was sick
they were in pain how could you deny
them something that would take that pain
away their last stage of life we have a
responsibility to libertarian philosophy
the libertarian platform the Libertarian
Party to present our ideas to maximize
individual liberty and minimize
government power in a way that actually
moves us forward in the American people
to get to that point you can't do it in
one fell swoop from a camp this says the
state's do it I'll give you a 10-second
answer it maybe shudder when I heard
John McCain say that his favorite
president was Teddy Roosevelt who's your
favorite president george washington
verma kinloch tie between Ronald Reagan
and Calvin Coolidge George Washington
far and away far and away Thomas
Jefferson was libertarian president in
history of America we'll talk later
about the Louisiana Purchase and what
that meant for the expansion of power
and slavery with that I'd like to wrap
up our terrific event thank you to all
of our guests please give them the great
round of a bar
thank you also to a date wife for
leading the repair thank you very much
this is a Ben Matt Welch for reason TV
good night